it what's cracking man it's your home
with little ride make sure you come
check me out on boot Lake Kev podcast or
see you there
man all right yo man bootleg cev podcast
bootleg cev show special guest here a
legend Lil Rob is here welcome thank you
big dog thank you man nice chilling
what's going on man uh just working on
some new music man got a new album
coming out November 3rd man on to the W
so just uh got to come out here and uh
hang out with you man and uh talk about
it man yeah it's crazy cuz like uh you
we were just talking a little bit you
guys like you know I I I talked to bash
a lot and he's like I'm busier now than
I've been my whole career yeah like you
guys I feel like every weekend I see you
guys doing like three or four shows
together yeah and I feel that too man uh
even me I'm more busy this time than I
ever was before too and uh it's just
different this time and uh I appreciate
it more so I like going out there and
making the people happy and everything
so it's been a really good time man so
yeah me bash and Magic been doing these
shows for the past like four years and
uh and just rocking it man you know what
I mean what do you what do you attribute
to that do you think it's like people
cuz I I think like music has kind of
been a weird place where like you know
we don't have a perfect example like a
lot of Tours this past summer got
cancelled but the ones that didn't get
canceled were like 50 cents tour and
Whiz Khalifa and snoop's tour I feel
like for whatever reason like if you're
coming from a certain era like the fans
like kind of miss that [__] because the
current music is you know it's a little
it's a little microwave if you will yeah
I mean I like a little bit of everything
man but uh you know who would have
thought that back in the days we would
write that kind of music that would last
you know as long as it has man and
hopefully it lasts forever you know what
I mean um but um to be a part of that is
is really really dope and and the fact
that me and fingers wrote a song called
Summer nights that kind of blew the hell
up and uh and uh yeah that's what I've
been uh surviving on for a long time B
Dog it's been good that's crazy yeah
know yeah yo when you wrote the line
right next to the Pacific to be specific
mhm it's one of the hardest lines ever
yeah I know I know it's like the
quential little Rob line yeah yeah you
know I've heard people make fun of it
sometimes man like oh why you put those
Rhymes together how do you do that all
the time but hey man you know I used to
live right there by the uh by the
Pacific to be specific so that's why man
everything was written in Anna's kitchen
right there in uh in my town so from the
beach I was going to say you kind of
like when I think of San Diego I mean
obviously recently there's been some
dope dudes out of San Diego but I think
of you I think of J felony I kind of
think you guys are kind of like the yeah
yeah the San Diego guys for you like
you've been carrying that San Diego flag
for so long like why do you think like
um San Diego still hasn't really popped
yet in terms of like mainstream hip-hop
uh I mean I don't really I don't really
pay attention to like what's really
going on like or why why it don't hit I
mean I guess if you just have a a hit
record then it's just going to it's just
going to happen you know what I mean
like even me like summer nights I
couldn't even stop it I didn't try to
write a hit record but it just kind of
happened that way and I think that's you
know whatever the people are digging at
the time I guess you know a lot of luck
I guess too you know hey everything yeah
there's a lot of luck involved with
right time right place right people and
all that you know yeah for sure um I was
going to ask you for you like seeing
kind of when you guys first came out I
feel like there was like the low rider
circuit obviously radio supported you
guys um there was kind of like this like
very small Collective of like Latin art
or Mexican artists doing hip-hop
um now I feel like it's gotten so big to
where like you know I never ever thought
that I would like see like a guy like
peso pluma oh yeah doing like the VMAs
right dopee or a guy like are you hip to
that Mexican OT oh yeah he's dope too
super dope like like I feel like I don't
too many of his jams or nothing like
that but but uh but when I have come
across him and hear him spit I way dope
though yeah it just feels like the the
like Mexican um space in hip-hop and
obviously I don't want to call P pluma
hip-hop cuz he's not but the Mexican
space in Hip Hop has grown to be like so
so big like there's so many like
Independent Artists artists getting
signed to major labels like um and you
guys are kind of like the forefathers of
a lot of that [__] you know what I'm
saying I'm pretty I'm pretty sure people
were rapping everywhere you know what I
mean like in San Diego and la and you
know Texas why just mean like in terms
of like they're being like a real like
recognition of like what able to see it
with the with the social media and
everything you know cuz back when I came
up it was uh you know proper do you know
what I mean meic power that Brown as
they tribe uh know Spanish fly from the
harbor area that I would bomb and then
there was like shows like pocco pedos
local who would like you later a little
bit later yeah right you would have to
like listen like Sunday nights in
Phoenix and you be able to like kind of
discover all these artists but I just
feel like now it's like it's like so big
like you know what I'm saying like in
terms of just the it feels like there's
a real movement like for you do you like
are you somebody who's gotten to the
point in your career where you're
looking like sign any artist or you just
kind of working on your own [__]
traveling I kind of know who the who I
was when I signed with the label you
know and what kind of a headache I was
to them you know by not showing up to
shows and doing you know they would set
up shows and everything and I would have
to you know go but sometimes I wouldn't
even show up or just wouldn't go or call
him that same morning and say I'm not
going to make it after there's been
promotion going on for that show and
everything you know what I mean too much
partying uh n i just not really wanting
to get get on the road man it wasn't
really like a thing to me you know what
I mean right a lot of a lot of [__]
at the pad too and stuff like that you
know what I mean so I just wouldn't end
up going and and really enjoying
everything man so but nowadays it's way
different is that why you said you
appreciate it more this time I
appreciate it a lot more now you know
what I mean and it's not for the money
it's not for the likes it's not for
anything like that like this new album
man I'm just coming back for the [__] of
it you know what I mean cuz I've been
doing shows for a long time with magic
and Bash and we've been selling them out
man so they're there to check us out man
and they' be asking me when's the new
music coming and I never have an answer
for them so but now now I do any
features on the new album n just on me
man that's dope working with fingers
again just because yeah 11 11 songs with
fingers we have one jam on there that
might not make it man this one probably
my favorite one on the jam but uh on the
thing but the trying to clear the sample
man then getting back at us so we got to
clear that sample man you yeah that's
tough you know what I mean y but uh so
your favorite song in the album might
not make it because of a sample
clearance one yeah one of my favorites
is really like you know like repping and
[__] you know what I mean do you know
what can you tell tell us what sample it
is I uh you know what man I can't even
think off hand which it it's it's a hard
to find oldi yeah so I'm oh they're
hitting you for sure they they get in
your pockets it's hard to find one they
getting back at us I said oh they're not
even getting back at you no we're
waiting we're waiting for a I said you
just let it fly for an answer you know
what I mean sometimes you got to just
let the sample fly yeah we'll see what
happens you know there's a guy named uh
there's a dude I know named static
selecta who's a big hip-hop producer and
he puts out albums and uh I always ask
him cuz he's independent and all his
Beats are samples oh yeah yeah and I'm
like dude you must have a hard time and
he's like no well that's like that's
like me too with everyone saying my
their favorite album is crazy life we
were sampling everything they get my
hands on with break beatss and right
that's why he's like dude we just drop
it and like if uh we hear about it it
means music's doing well yeah yeah too
man yeah for sure yeah so you clear it
later yeah yeah you know what I mean
yeah um talk about uh for you man how
dope has it kind of been to like when
cuz I feel like when you when I got into
radio in
2005 and I think the first time I might
have saw you live was maybe like 06 or
07 but I was like working at a radio in
Phoenix when neighborhood music like
popped off like that [__] was like a
real wave it was like that you had the
song neighborhood music yeah yeah 2004
yeah you had uh bring out the freak in
you trying to think of all your radio
singles that we
played those are the ones that come to
my mind yeah well barely getting by the
got on the radio barely getting by was
dope okay Co for sure for sure and then
obviously summer nights or summer nights
but um at that same time magic had sexy
lady and obviously MB Riders head what
they were doing is it dope to kind of be
able to like like be side by side with a
guy like magic and be like look how far
we've come like you know what I'm saying
oh yeah yeah we go way back too man we
been in San Diego cuz uh I believe he
wanted to sign me at one point or
something like that there he wanted to
ass you yeah I think so yeah yeah I
think so and work together and stuff and
but I end working with the same label
and we ended up was that upstairs
putting things out yeah upstairs records
yeah yeah yeah they had I mean upstairs
records had everybody so then we uh you
know I was go to uh I went to Phoenix to
work with with magic and we did uh
California M and City everyone knows um
so yeah we worked together from the gate
go and then obviously even like a guy
like Baby Bash who's kind of turned into
everyone's favorite like high Uncle yeah
yeah yeah yeah for sure man I was just
saying man I was on the way here I was
running a little bit late and I was
stressing out a little bit so I I
started puffing on a joint that uh the
Bashers team gave me so um that cherry
wave so yeah shout out to bash for that
bash passes you weed you got to you just
got to make sure you know oh yeah yeah I
don't smoke like that I smoke you got a
few hours to yourself you know yeah yeah
for sure dog for sure so you're high
right now uh it's a little bit I feel
good yeah b a couple puffs and that's it
what's your biggest Market these days
like what do you know is like that one
market like no matter what they're
showing out for you well I say I would
say Los Angeles man and it's so big too
where you got you could do a show over
here and over here and over there and
yeah you do like Still rocking there's
so many little areas of La yeah yeah a
big market for me man so even that with
you know hooking up with the ston for
this video and everything almost like
showing love to to La too you know
um yeah of course he's a legend yeah
yeah for sure man and uh you know
talking about getting stuck like uh like
uh like it's a Friday you know in
traffic in La you know what I mean and
um you don't want to get stuck in life
like that did he direct the new video oh
yeah he directed the new video yeah did
you watch his Netflix documentary that
they did about him and cartoon that [__]
was sick yeah do do yeah cartoon did
these for me man the 12 did 128 yeah
that's how much was that did he did he
hit you like Peak Mr cartoon prices for
those uh I don't remember man I think we
were just [__] chilling and listening
to some moldies and having a couple
beers I feel like back then Mr cartoon
could have charged anything for attach
rappers would have been like yeah no I
think he I think he hooked me up pretty
nicely man it was dope thank you shout
out to cartoon man what's up shout out
to Mr cartoon yeah yeah been a minute
been a minute for sure um ston shot the
uh the cover for neighborhood music damn
that's crazy that shot that so that's
back in 2004 man wow so we go way back
too you know way back are you aware that
like people kind of look at you as like
kind of like the the JayZ of Cho rap do
you like understand that like that's
like cuz whenever we think about Cho rap
like you are the god of it man yeah no I
mean I hear it man but you know just
just always just like going to the
studio and and uh doing my thing man so
that part doesn't really doesn't really
uh the noise and all the like extra [__]
doesn't really come across your radar
not really man I mean it does it comes
across my radar but I don't really like
it's kind of like deflected kind of like
a little bit because it doesn't make
doesn't do me I don't know I got no
opinion on it you know yeah man it's a
trip though but I don't look at myself
like that and I just kind of like and I
think maybe that's why the people dig
what I'm doing I don't know just kind of
works right I always wonder coming from
San Diego there is kind of like a weird
like rivalry between San Diego and LA
uhhuh but and and same thing with
Phoenix like Phoenix and La has this big
rivalry especially when it comes to
sports but like uh La is like always
embraced you always embraced magic in
such a crazy way for you like was it a
little harder for you to be a guy from
San Diego and break like up top in in LA
or or was it like pretty easy just
because of what you were doing yeah I
think it was pretty easy just because of
what I was doing you know yeah but uh a
big part of me when I first started was
uh and big shout out to Spanish flight
from the harbor area I would listen to
them man and uh and uh always dug what
they were doing with the all the samples
and everything um so I mean that's kind
of like where I started at so you know
big shout out to Al I was listening to
La music already too you know yeah but
this is way back in the like 90 90 that
like 90 or something like that when the
Chargers moved to LA are you still like
a charger fan no I pretty much stopped
watching football man you were just like
when it when it was San Diego Chargers
that was one thing you know Angeles
Chargers and you got you know you got
other teams to Los Angeles they don't
need I just be so heartbroken I couldn't
imagine like my football team leaving to
like a different city yeah well luckily
I wasn't into it that much to be like
heartbroken it's just like whatever so
now now I just uh yeah I don't really
watch
there's the pad you got the padr man
what who has the best Mexican food San
Diego or LA yo we got to stop the
interview again and tell you about our
folks at odd Soxs baby that's right
shout out to odd Soxs man the most
comfortable socks in the world they've
been riding with us since day one um and
let me tell you something man Christmas
time is is really sneaking up um
oddsocks official.com use the promo code
bootleg save 20% off at checkout they
got the crazy licenses check out these
Naruto socks [__] fire little
SpongeBob socks you know what I'm saying
how about this how about the how high
movie socks they got the WWE they got
the [__] Cheeto socks you know
what I'm saying shout out to the
[__] Cheeto socks they just
dropped their Monopoly line too I'm
waiting for them to send them to me Ahad
send me the Monopoly [__] buddy all
right also the odd Soxs Basics these are
my favorites they're just normal just
you know the most comfortable socks
you've ever put on your feet is really
what they are get them black white red
[__] tie-dye whatever you're into and
they got the underwear baby little
Reese's boys let's go odd Soxs
official.com use the promo code bootleg
they got South Park underwear too all
the licenses WWE scarf phas Breaking Bad
South Park Power Rangers monopo cocacola
they got it all use that promo code
bootleg and save 20% off at checkout
also want to give a shout out to our
sponsor uh much love to our good Folks
at bluechew that's right we talk about
it all the time on the podcast when you
go to blu.com right now you can get your
first month for free a lot of people ask
well what is blue and does it work well
blue it has the same active ingredient
as Viagra and Calis the only difference
is you don't have to go to the doctor
it's all online you go to blu.com you
get your [__] handled over there and
then they get you handled by sending you
a month for free when you use the promo
code bootleg blu.com promo code bootleg
try out blue Chu it'll have your uh
your
dick harder than it's ever been it's
like trigonometry in high school real
hard you know if you're dealing with any
sort of erectile
dysfunction uh blue will have you right
like I said same active ingredient as
viagran Calis minus the awkward doctor's
appointment everything's online and if
you're asking well I don't know man I
just don't know try it out for free for
a month they'll send you a month supply
for free right to your doorstep in
discreete packaging blue chewable form
it's in a little it's a little chewable
man you take that thing down and then
you go to Pound Town take your shorty to
Pound Town godamn it blue.com use that
promo code bootleg try it for free for a
month let's get back to the interview I
don't know but I'm like a taco shop type
of dude like the San Diego taco shops
you know yeah I I say it's I always tell
everybody the best Mexican food I always
look at proximity to the Border San
Diego's got the best Mexican food yeah
in my opinion I don't think it's close
and then it's
LA and other places yeah yeah that's
that's that was say always say San
Diego's number one now yeah I would say
that too but like I said but I never I
never ate it everywhere you know what I
mean so I don't know you know if I
didn't hit the right place in La La or
something like that you know yeah I just
like can't blame all that late or
something you know and the best food
I've ever eaten is in Tijana Tiana has
the best [__] Seafood I've ever had
in my life get it man do you have like
do you make it over there to get like I
haven't been over there for a long time
dude I used to go to TJ when I was like
16 yeah I go I don't I don't have health
insurance so I go over there and get
like you know oh see the dentist go down
there man when my first uh record came
out over the night in the 619 and in
Mexican gangsters I was in ' 92 and I
was out there uh outside of Elo Pub and
you know passing out my my records back
then D I was 16 years old 16 years old
in TJ passing out your your your CD yeah
my brother and then went up went up into
the show cuz uh there was I don't I
forgot who was performing that night I
think itbe was Kid Frost and I don't
know I don't know who it was but they
all went in but I was too young they
wouldn't let me in but I was passing on
my albums man damn so your first album
was 92 my first uh it's a single but
just over n songs yeah so first time you
actually released any music Rel anything
yeah 92 man that's crazy cassette tape
yeah and the record longevity man yeah
that's what I'm saying man and you can't
I mean I couldn't plan for it just kind
of happened that way you know yeah but I
appreciate it and everything man so what
would be like everything you you said
earlier that you know you kind of went
through your spouts with the not showing
up to shows and maybe taking advantage
of the [__] a little bit yeah yeah yeah
exactly for any young uh upand cominging
artists for you know you've obviously
kind of made mistakes that you know
maybe they could learn from what would
be some things you would uh you would
advise them to do I made mistakes that I
could learn from or that I learned from
and people other people's made mistakes
towards me that that I've learned from
you know what I mean so it's uh you know
never step on nobody's toes don't burn
no Bridges cuz you never know man uh be
humble but e either you are humble or
you're not you know what I mean so you
can't act like you're humble you know uh
either you are you're not so um and uh
just never never burn nobody man cuz you
just never know man you know yeah yeah
never burn a bridge very keep your word
and everything man always keep your word
you know and you're you were you came
early today and I was late so be you
know you know and and we're doing this
in the morning oh yeah yeah no not for
sure man I was at notb Farm last night
till 2: in the morning so yeah I just do
from Vegas last night you know and then
went to go eat over here at mama how how
Vegas is always a movie yeah that was
dope at the House of Blues at Mandalay
Bay was it you magic uh bash was someone
else on me magic bash jrocks uh shout
out to J Rock she's got a beautiful
voice yeah um I forget a couple others
but yeah I forget Sophia Marie you guys
are doing so many shows together have
you ever considered doing like a Best of
Both Worlds or like a a Westside
Connection type of album where it's like
you bash and magic and maybe it's like
10 songs they were talking about doing
some jams you know that would be crazy
we did a couple jams already me and me
and magic and uh we have one that's
coming out on uh on Magic's album I
guess well you guys had did a record
like three or four years ago with that
uh what's that kid's name Oho CUO I was
going to say koku [__] but that song was
[__] raw yeah that went pretty big
man so that song was that was a
beautiful song yeah man that dude's sick
yeah yeah he's got a beautiful voice and
that and that's the thing too man I was
doing a I did something for jrocks did
something for Spanish Fly Astic tribe
little Grio from San Diego um who else
uh
uh quatro Prestigio the one for them too
go check it out that's a good one man to
abanda you know so shout out to you guys
too man um but uh I just got hipped to a
new dude from San Diego have you heard
of him I think his name is little weirdo
uhhuh have you heard of him uh I heard
of him yeah yeah yeah he's pretty dope
yeah he's good he's good and then
there's um God damn it I can't think of
the kid's name what's the kid's name
from uh Oceanside that's doing the old
school Desi Hollow Desi Hollow Desi
Hollow too man
yeah way cool man so I liked what he was
doing so he hit him up but I've done so
many features lately where I thought
maybe it was just time to do my own you
know what I mean yeah's dope man I like
how he's kind of bringing back that like
G
Funk and he's younger like he's like
he's just like paying homage like and
he's doing it in like a great way it's
like he dope super dope for sure shout
out to Oceanside man yeah for sure 760
in the house Oceanside is like a place
you drive through on your way to San
Diego but you don't realize if you just
get off the freeway it's [__]
gorgeous no I'll be driving through
tomorrow what is your Chemistry like
these days with a guy like fingas cuz
fingas for people who don't know he had
a run like fingas really had a run
everyone goes to fingers man got some
good get some good jams man so I already
knew that he was the person that I
needed to to go see you know so he's
mainly handling is it all the production
or a lot of the production on this uh
all of it all of it all of it man that's
dope that's I like that too like in
hip-hop where people like lock in with
one producer cuz I feel like it always
makes the albums better oh need clean
dude and he helps me write the the hooks
and everything man and uh I go in there
we knock it out real quick and then
we'll add his flavor to it and it's it's
all to the good you know yeah are you
guys going to um are you going to put it
out and just see how the fans react are
you going to go to radio with this or
like what's what's kind of the plan we
got a plan going on man which you know I
wasn't really ready for either man cuz
at first I was just going to throw it
out just for the people you know so now
we're here doing uh you know the podcast
thing and just doing little interviews
here and there and just uh doing it
because this is what we do you know what
I mean and um so yeah we're going to put
it out hopefully the people love it man
it's bumping that's dope that's one my
favorite favorite uh things I put
together in a long time how long did it
take you to
record uh just three sessions we did
three sessions 11 songs real quick man
you know [__] y'all were quick yeah well
I get my stuff already ready in my head
and everything so when I go to the
studio I don't you already have the beat
you know what's crazy cuz the new
rappers don't do that no more they just
show up to the studio they play like 10
beats and then they start humming uh
yeah they go in the booth and they that
I could do that too but so you like to
get the Beats have everything ready so
when you get in we're we're on business
I'm ready to record I already record and
everything's ready to go and I put
thought into my rhyme and you know make
sure they're put together when I spin
them right and all that have you uh how
many people have little Rob tattoos in
the world right now I don't know but
I've seen a couple man about say I've
seen some yeah yeah that's got to be
some my my autograph on their on their
skin or whatever or uh or just portraits
too that's PR I was going to say if
someone has a portrait of your face on
them and they come up to you that's got
to be cool but also a little startling
yeah that's cool well one one chick
wanted me to ride ride on her face you
know what I mean but I don't want to do
that I would have been like listen do
nah you don't want listen thank you you
want do that yeah yeah thank you but no
thanks but n you don't you don't want to
ruin your life yeah yeah for sure that's
crazy that is crazy you're just walking
around with a little Rob tattoo on your
face going to job interviews and [__]
explaining it I don't understand but
that's cool you know yeah like you guys
don't know little Rob this is yeah yeah
what what where's the like like the
portrait shit's got to be pretty gnarly
though like do you like take their
information and say hey I'm going to
like get you into the show or or you
just like hey thank you uh that kind of
reposted on my story and stuff like that
yeah so but never really thought about
inviting to a show but maybe that's a
good idea you know I feel like if
someone gets their your face tattooed on
them they should get into the show yeah
for sure all right cool yo what up guys
we got to stop the interview to tell you
about our folks at my bookie it's
winning season right now NFL we're in
the thick of it I've been doing really
good on my NFL bets by the way plus NBA
officially back we got playoff baseball
it's going crazy especially if you like
to throw down some of that money and do
a little gambling you got to head over
to mybookie uh this was dumb about
mybookie it doesn't matter if your team
sucks my team the Cardinals they're
trash don't matter I'm still winning on
Sundays baby all right at my bookie all
right you can use my bookie for your
daily odd boost same game parlays and
take advantage of the crazy huge prize
pool contest plus right now my bookie
has a no strings attached that's the
important thing no strings attached cash
bonus that let you deposit and withdraw
quick that's free cash no strings
attached deposit take it out and then go
about your day or get in on some of this
NFL and NBA action baby all right just
use the promo code bootleg when you sign
up go to mybookie.ag use the promo code
bootleg on your first deposit and you'll
receive up to $200 in cash what are we
talking about no strings attached what
my bookie use the promo code bootleg all
right maybe you want to gamble on some
NFL maybe you want to get in on some of
this early NBA action maybe you want to
get in on some of this playoff baseball
it's really on you use the promo code
bootleg and receive up to $200 in cash
that's right try my bookie right now use
that promo code bootleg and you can grab
um how about this man there's some crazy
odds going on and I like this one
because what you can do is you can throw
down on a potential Super Bowl front
runner and uh plus
38,000 on the Eagles and Chiefs on the
Super Bowl plus 388,000
if you put
$100 you win
$38,000 you're not going to get those
odds anywhere my bookie.ag use the promo
code bootleg right now bet anything
anytime anywhere only with my bookie
plus we got to give a big shout out to
our family at King pom man we love King
pom over here on the bootle C podcast
this is what's great about King P first
of all it's all about about that organic
no tobacco leaf this thing right here is
a boy look at that that's just a leaf
right there King pal they got everything
you need man they got these cones with
the squeezing pop tpin in them the
flavors this right here is the uh the
dragon fruit we got the grape HD the
watermelon wave so many flavors what's
dope about King pal if you're in
whatever City you're in you can find
King pal at your local smoke shop your
local 7-Eleven all right I'm telling you
King palom you're not going to ever ever
experience a more cleaner more natural
more just great way to smoke with you
smoking all right you stuff one of these
boys up with some flour uh and and you
just you're Off to the Races I'm telling
you you hit the tip you get hit with
that flavor and it's man it's nothing
like it the squeeze and pop on King
palom is insane all right and they got
all siiz cones all right so go to King
pom man organic tobacc free leaves of
all sizes like this is a this is a this
is look look we're talking about all
sizes here what are we talking about
what are we talking about here boys all
right go to King pom.com right now you
can order whatever you want man they got
accessories they got trays they got
Grinders they got ash trays they got
damn all kind of flavors of their leaves
everything 50% off when you use the
promo code bootleg that's 50% off order
whatever you want at King pom.com let's
get back to the interview yeah that's
pretty gnarly we'll start that for next
year let's do it
yeah um what' you say the name of the
new album was uh all to the Bueno
because no matter what it's all to the
Bueno I like that yeah uh coming out
when no uh November 3rd November 3rd
November 3rd are you going to do any
like hard copies so you can sell them on
the road and stuff doing that do the
merch and all that you got the merch
together yeah for sure yeah that's dope
man well it's dope to see you back
making new music yeah it's going to be
fun cuz you've been on the road just
murdering it how many shows a year are
we at right now I don't even pay
attention I'm just never if you had a
guess I mean it was it like 100 shows a
year I'll just take that yeah it's a lot
it's a lot D lot dude it's crazy man you
got from here I mean a lot of West Coast
but then also to New York and uh and um
new what we had uh New York and uh
Atlanta and what is uh what is I was
going to say that is interesting cuz
like I you wouldn't think like a New
York show would be big for little Rob
what are like like the fans like in New
York you know what I mean like that's
different was a good show too man we
packed the house in uh in the Queens in
Queens that's crazy so that was sh in
Queens it was it was bumping I'm curious
um do you are you hip like there's like
this whole Chico subculture in Japan
yeah have they ever booked you guys out
there I went out there what like in 2005
I think with Eman for Power 106 shout
out to Eman man shout out to em man and
um we did a 5 City tour in uh in Japan
how how crazy and I went to uh they got
low riders and [__] out there oh yeah
had the bumper yeah H yeah some dude uh
Japanese dude put up pulled up a shirt
on me for said you kind of want to
on his stomach that was pretty crazy
that is kind of
crazy Japanese guy with chicag he looked
all gangster out too man you know that
[__] is crazy yeah oh [__] shout out to
uh yeah shout out to that guy man he's
committed yeah you know yeah for sure
dog hey love it I miss um some you know
there's still like some some car shows
that are pretty big out there the
Arizona super shows big shout out to my
guy Kenny who does it every year but
like the peak Low Rider
was so crazy every year every rapper had
their own like Booth set up there was
like half naked chicks everywhere there
was the car show Girls every I mean it
was wild what is like the craziest low
rider show story you got cuz those
things got pretty gnarly and like I mean
it in a really good way but it was it
was great yeah well I guess uh I guess
uh ler show that I had done I guess up
in uh San Francisco mhm yeah the cops
made me put a bulletproof vest on
wow yeah cuz there was some some threats
going on and uh but I had the
neighborhood music at summer nights and
so I went up there to go perform that
for them and then uh you had was the
threats just the Southern California
Northern California politics but I got
no problem with any anything like that
I'm show I'm there to show everybody a
good time man you know when when I'm on
the stage I Rocka Brown bandana
represent brown pride and and that means
you know that means everybody everybody
man I ain't tripping you know what I
mean I I ain't doing that stuff so um so
yeah just the bottles being thrown at me
and stuff like that it was kind of crazy
man they threw bottles at you they threw
some soda on me too it a cup of soda on
my hat my brain was Dripping uh oh man
ding uh whatever but you know it's not
everybody man it's just a few people
that that might act that way man so it's
I got to show you this video real quick
cuz this is uh this was in 2009 in Boise
I was at Wild
101 and this was me and you chugging a
beer on stage at the Knitting
Factory and I look like a 12-year-old
cuz I was a 12-year-old I was 21 maybe
20 This Is
Us
[Music]
okay damn get it
dog oh well okay [__] going way
back long time ago yeah damn yeah damn
dude the Latin lockdown tour was that
Lil Uno I don't was it Latin lock down
toour I think that was like I did one of
them yeah I think that was like I'm
trying to think who else was on that
show I want to say uh the Superman guy
brown boy was on that show okay shout
out to brown boy man I just ran into him
yeah yeah see him in a minute yeah yeah
look man you're killing it I'm glad to
see you guys on this on on the road just
showing um artists like it's not all
about just streaming you know what I
mean if you make real connections with
your fans you could eat forever yeah
well I'm just yeah like like I said I'm
just out there having fun you know what
I mean I'm just uh proud that they're
even wanting to see me still you know
what I mean yeah making timeless music
is important because you can uh you can
turn that into like long real longevity
yeah yeah for sure cuz a lot of people
can't do how many however many shows a
year you guys are doing is crazy yeah
for a minute for a minute honestly man I
was I didn't know what I was doing uh
Magic had hit us up for uh to see if we
want to go do these shows and everything
man so I said okay cool let's do it and
then um that's just kind of when it
started but before that like 5 years
whatever I wasn't really doing too much
yeah no out to Magic Magic's a Visionary
um he's got the for people who don't
know if you go to um any MC Magic
Show even uh I want to say even when you
were performing he's standing on the
side of the stage running the show with
his son no yeah yeah yeah like Magic's
just standing there there's the graphics
and like him and his kid are like
handling everything yeah yeah it's crazy
yeah for sure I got the whole family
Family Affair thing going on man and uh
you know even me lately I've been taking
my son too's 4 years old he been rocking
summer nights with me at the show that's
dope man man I be taking my family with
me four you know when I can yeah four
they say um I think that's you know when
people say terrible twos I really think
it's terrible fours yeah cuz they think
they're like little grownups he's a
little gangster man yeah when someone's
four they like they start the kids start
to think they're like you know somebody
yeah I took him out on on the stage with
me at the uh at the long be show Bobby D
show sh Bobby D yeah and it was uh so I
took him out there I had him in my arms
he was 3 years old and I put him on my
arms and just just carry while I did
summer nights and everything man then I
put him down he started rocking the mic
by himself and I go okay let's go let's
go so that's that's way cool man he's
the real low Rob yeah yeah little little
Rob yeah for sure now I am yeah all
right the album's coming out November
November 3rd November 3rd yeah yeah Al
to the Bueno all to the Bueno go check
it out check it out you got a single out
called too too much right now thought
them V be talking too much and then uh
and then moment in time right now and uh
right now tons of shows you can probably
whatever City you're in especially if
you're anywhere in the West Coast I'm
sure you're going to be coming soon oh
yeah yeah for sure I'll be I'll be back
in Pomona and Los Angeles I think in
November I think and then uh but uh yeah
I'll be in Salt Lake City this weekend
man on Saturday shout out to the Mormons
man yeah for sure man choose the right
yeah appreciate you brother thank you
man thank you man thank you what's going
on man I want to shout out to our family
a hardan for presenting to you another
interview all right there's another
interview coming tomorrow and the next
day and the next day shout out to harden
though if you're in Las Vegas man the
number one dispensary in the world there
are family there are brothers there are
[__] dogs over there man we love them
they always are taking care of us and
they'll take care of you if you go to
Hardin in Vegas let's say you're Landing
in Vegas you're going to go watch the
Raiders you're going to go watch a Vegas
show whatever get in that taxi tell them
straight up take me to harden when you
get to Hardin they will get you hooked
up with the craziest uh just variety and
selection of Premium cannabis on the
planet and if you tell them you heard
about us on the on on the bootleg C show
you say hey Harden I heard about y'all
on the bootleg C podcast they're gonna
take care of y'all all right so go
follow him Hardin Las Vegas on all
social media and check them out Hardin
Las vegas.com what's up Harden